today we got the commitment of our
partners that training courses will
start and we will build up together a
construction of this Consortium of
fighter jets it will start with the F-16
with the Netherlands and Denmark as the
leaders and other countries will join
and also we heard good news from our
Sweden Partners also that we will have
the options to testing testing just just
testing there capabilities also we had a
session today with a variety of
countries where early in the planning
process I I think there's a an intent by
several countries that have stepped up
to take the lead Netherlands and in
Denmark in terms of the planning so
there's a lot of work left to be done I
think we'll be prematured and give a
specific date on any time that F-16 is
there any other type of advanced
aircraft would be employed in combat in
Ukraine there's a lot of work to do you
have to do language training you have to
do pilot training you've got all the
systems set in place so those wheels are
in motion but we're away from completion
of that project we have and we will
continue to offer wide-ranging support
from providing sophisticated combined
arms capabilities to intelligence to
training of Ukrainian forces to be more
effective on the battlefield
through a global effort
more than six thousand ukrainians are
being trained right now
at 40 different locations training
locations
in 65 courses in 33 Nations
on three continents that is all
happening right now today